on retrouve tout de suite caroline de
camaret sur place sommet de versailles
marque-t-il une étape dans la
construction de l'europe
oui tout à fait vous savez que les chefs
d'état et gouvernement se sont réveillés
un petit peu groggy parce qu'ils ont
fini de parler effectivement ukraine à
1h30 du matin et aujourd'hui
effectivement et bien il s'attaque à la
question de la croissance en europe une
croissance qui est
effectivement en berne on tablait sur 4
% pour cette année dans les dernières
prévisions de la commission européenne
aujourd'hui on s'achemine plutôt vers 3
% et en vérité ce qui se passe c'est une
situation quasi de stagflation c'est à
dire une stagnation
avec une inflation très forte à 100% la
patronne de la banque centrale
européenne est d'ailleurs ici même au
sommet de versailles aujourd'hui pour
redire qu'elle pour l'instant elle
temporise sur les prix alors que faire
par rapport à ça c'est l'envol et bien
sûr des prix du pétrole qui ont augmenté
de 140% depuis le début de l'année et du
240 % pour le gaz pardon et 50% pour le
pétrole et puis l'envol est aussi des
céréales du blé bref nous sommes dans
cette situation où il pourrait y avoir
pour nos démocraties un danger de
rébellion populaire de révolte type
gilet jaune face à une envolée des prix
pour l'ukraine en l'occurrence et pour
une guerre en ukraine les vingt-sept
donc sont décidés à essayer de prendre
un de retrouvé le chemin de la
croissance pour la crise du coup vite
souvenez vous il avait mis sur la table
un plan de relance à 750 milliards
d'euros a été financé par une dette en
commun et certains pays les pays du sud
et puis un petit peu la france aussi
voudrait que eh bien on fasse bis
repetita ce qu'on prévoit aussi une
croissance tirée par une nouvelle dette
en commun d'être spécifique par rapport
à la résilience sur la crise
l'ukrainienne pour pouvoir diversifier
nos approvisionnements et pouvoir mieux
résister à cette crise justement
rapidement caroline les européens vont
ils prendre des mesures pour renforcer
leur indépendance énergétique à court
terme vis-à-vis de la russie
tout à fait ils ont exclu l'idée d'un
embargo sur le pétrole et le gaz à la
différence des américains parce qu'ils
sont trop dépendants à 30% pour le
pétrole est à 40 % pour le gaz en
revanche ils vont à court terme et c'est
à dire pour cette année à 2022 avant
septembre reconstituer des réserves à
90% et puis essayer de diversifier à
nouveau leur approvisionnement la
patronne de la commission européenne les
a même en juin d'ici 2027 à être
totalement indépendant du gaz russe mais
vous voyez que ça n'est pas pour tout de
suite l'indépendance totale il faut la
construire pas à pas et c'est ce que les
vingt-sept sont en train de faire grâce
à ce sommet et au prochain bien entendu
aussi à suivre
fin mars le 24 et 25 mars merci beaucoup
caroline de camaret merci à vous